but speaking of photos so is there a
reason that this one is your profile
pick on all your social media cuz this
is awesome this first of all we would
have been friends just from this photo
like you should I wish I should have had
mine to put right next to yours 100% so
wait I I I love this why pick this one
this oh my gosh it's so funny this look
how serious you were even as a youngster
like I'm this is so I was if you could
see the badges I was a prefect and basic
my school won an award for the most
healthy eating School in the county and
all the kids put their name in a hat and
I pick my name out and I that's me next
to my head teacher holding an award for
the healthiest eating school and I can
do my top button up so I'm obsessed with
it I love it I love it it's body
positivity would have been friends yeah
I love I loved food I still love I still
do I love food you know why I love food
because it tastes great but also it's
the it's it's you're always around
others you're always having such a great
time with it yeah that's that's what it
is to me my I think I prefer food to
music which is a big thing to say cuz I
love music wow food's my everything
that's a close tie for me I thought you
were going to go somewhere else and I
was like totally oh no no that comes
third third
[Music]
exactly
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home